翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Riaki Poništ
よろしくお願いします
（笑）
みなさん 何かしら一つ
こだわりがあると思うんです
今日は僕は「外見に凝ったっていいじゃん」
というタイトルで
もっと みんな 外見にこだわっても
いいと思ってるんですよ
まあこんな格好で言うのも
あれなんですけどね
（笑）
口笛も皆さん人生初だと思うし
ふんどしで話してる奴も初めてだと思うので
（笑）
概してランチ後っていうのは
眠くなりますから
寝ないようにして欲しいなと思います
では プレゼン始めさせて頂きます
よろしくお願いします
（笑）（拍手）
僕の 今日２つのこだわりを
話したいと思います
１つ目は筋肉です
僕は 筋肉の研究を まあ生理学ですね —
の研究をしているんです
僕が なぜ筋肉にこだわるのかというのを
まずお話ししたいと思います
僕は 高校時代
アメリカンフットボールってものを
やってたんです
だから そもそも鍛えなくちゃ
いけなかったんですね
敵に勝つために
で 僕は結果的に自分の体を自分で
デザインすることに徐々に喜びを覚えて
着替えを始めてったんですね
あ 着替えじゃない 間違った
（笑）
筋トレを始めてった訳です
大学では怪我もあり
健康のことを学ぶ大学に行きました
で 健康行動というものを学びます
そこから 筋肉が好きすぎて
僕は筋肉の研究をすることにしたんですね
毎日バナナを食べ プロテインを飲み
筋トレをするっていう生活を
毎日送っていた訳です
僕は それがこだわりなんですけど
もう１つ こだわりが高じすぎて
僕はトレーナーをやり始めたんです
僕にとってのこだわりを
そういう風に 人に伝えていった訳ですね
最初 目的は健康になるとか
筋肉を付けさせるとか
脂肪を減らすとかだったんです
ただやってみて
面白いことに気づいたんです
もちろんみんな最初は
「早く痩せさせてくれよ」とか
「でかくなりてえんだ」とか
言ってるんですけど
やってくうちに「あ 自分の身体
こういう風に鍛えていくんだ」ってことで
そもそも過程を 楽しみ始めたんです
どういう風に腕立てやるかとかね
そういうことに関して
みんな面白がっていく訳です
それが徐々に 面白いなあって思って
僕は アイドルとか経営者とか
アーティストだったりですね
（笑）
アーティストとかに教えてって
みんなが身体を変えていく間に
意外に 内面まで変わっていくってことに
面白いなって思い始めたんです
そんなある日 僕のところに
あるお客さんが来たんです
それが今回のお話のキーである
山本さんという方との出会いです
山本さんはですね 始めから言うと
こだわりはスーツだったんですよね
ただ 僕は最初はスーツには興味がなくて
彼はすごい楽しくスーツの話を
してくれるんですけど
僕はやっぱり他人事だった訳です
それはなぜか？
まあ 気持ちは分かると思うんですけど
鍛えてる人は大体分かるんですが
大体ですね 身体を鍛え始めると
服がなくなっていくんです
どんどん着られる服がなくなっていく
僕の身体っていうのは腕が太くて短い
首が太い 肩幅がある
足も短くてむっちりしてるっていう
もう最低なんです
服を着るには最低の身体で
だから もうどんどんこう —
ここに引っ張ると突っ張られたりして
おしゃれがしたくなくなるんです
だから興味がなかった
でもですね その山本さんは
僕とトレーニングをして
僕がトレーニングについての
熱意を語りながら
こそっと 僕に聞いてくれるような言葉で
彼が話してくれた
それは
「星野くんは類い稀なる
ムチムチの身体を持っている訳で
でも実はそれこそが
オーダーメイドスーツを着ると肩幅もあるし
君だけの身体とファッションを
表現できるんだよ」ということを
言ってくれた訳です
他にも山本さんは
どういう風に着るかとか
今の職人がどういう問題を持ってるかと
いうことを色々教えてくれたんですけども
一番何が僕にとって
印象的だったかというと
着る服がなくてクソ面倒臭いと
思っていた僕が
自分だからこそ —
この身体だからこそ
表現できるファッションがあるってことに
気づいたってことなんです
それが僕が２年前
全くスーツに興味がなかったところから
スーツに興味を持ち始めて
今ではオーダースーツとかを頼んで
その過程を楽しんでるところまで
チェンジした訳です
で 実は僕は来月から１年間イタリアで
スーツの留学をしてきます
俗にいう
「筋肉スーツ留学」ってやつですよね
（笑）
まあ よくあるやつですよ
新しい分野が開拓された訳です
で だから 僕はその２年間を通して
山本さんとこだわりの交換
というものを行ってきた訳です
彼は僕にスーツというものを教えてくれたし
僕は彼に —
今の彼は朝に駒沢公園で
10キロとか走ったりしてますから
僕よりは全然
長距離ランニングをしている訳です
こうやって 価値の交換を行う
僕は今日それをみなさんに伝えたいんです
だから最初タイトルを僕は
「筋肉」という肩書きで
服を着ずに来たんですけども
今日は実は
「外見に凝ったっていいじゃん？」—
その２つ目のタイトルは
皆さんにスーツの魅力を伝えたい
と思って来ています
僕はスーツに関わって
２つのことに気づいたんです
１つ目 それは外見から変えられる
自分があるっていうことです
（笑）
トレーニングを通して
みんな外見から内面に変わっていったし
僕自身もこうやって
自分をおしゃれにすることで
より人前で話すのが楽しくなってきた
で ですね —
（笑）
あのね 喋りながら着るのって
非常に難しいです
（笑）
初めてですから
で 僕が面白いと思ったのは
みんなスーツにこだわればこだわるほど
手間がかかるんです
まず 最初 普通にみなさん
量販店で買いますよね
ここも学生が多いから
それが一番最初だったと思います
で オーダースーツっていうものの
一回入り口を踏むと
３万円から５万円かも知れないですけど
１回仮縫いっていうものがあって
結局頼んでから自分の身体のサイズを
確かめに行かなければいけない
で もっと フルオーダーっていう手作りになると
２回行かなきゃいけない
そうするとですね
服が欲しいと思ってから
２ヶ月後に入るんです
で もっと興味を持ち始めて
ナポリとかミラノから来たテーラーから頼むと
３ヶ月、半年、１年とかになるんです
僕がもし 留学で スーツ作りたいですって
ナポリを頼んで１年かかったら
もう帰ってきちゃう
もう すげえ時間がかかる訳ですよ
でも そこまでやって
彼らが何をしたいかっていうと
その過程を楽しんでいる訳です
僕もですね 最初 ボタンがどうやるかとか
すごい難しかったですし
この着こなしや組み合わせをどうするかとか
確かに最初は面倒臭いんです
だから その過程を僕は
スーツを初めて作った人たちと
工房があるんですけど そこにはバーがあって
サロンみたいなのがあるんですよ
だから僕は また着こなしを覚えて
新しいグッズを買ったり もしくは
報告しに行ったりすると
お酒がただで出て そのスーツの
会話を楽しんでる訳です
で これも留学が受かってから
注文して２ヶ月くらい待って
楽しみに待っていたんですけど
結局その方にもこうやってTEDxの話とかを
後日 報告しに行くことになってるんですね
僕が今日伝えたかったのは
ナポリとかの注文をしている人たちも
結局３ヶ月、半年かけて
50万とか100万とかかけて
毎回注文している訳です
で 結局 その僕の知人の方が
一言 言ったのは
「僕が欲しいのは
スーツそのものじゃなくて」
コスタンティーノという
ナポリ人なんですけど
「彼の持ってくる生地の提案が楽しみで
お金を払っている」と
僕は 静的な物を手にいれる
ということではなく
その過程を楽しむこだわりというのを
今日みなさんに伝えたいんです
確かにお金を払えば
すぐに物は手に入る訳ですけど
物のやりとりというのは そういうこと
じゃないんだよということを伝えたいんです
だから 先ほど登場した山本さんや
ナポリ人やその他の日本人の
スーツ好きの人に聞いてみると
やっぱ問題があって
それは後継者不足っていうことなんです
これは 世界的な問題です
当然 イタリア —
僕が来月から行くのは
その問題をなんとか解決しなければ
ならないと思って行くんですけど
要するに みんなもう作っているのは
おじいちゃんなんです
テーラーとか行くと 30〜40歳代の
おしゃれなお兄さんが対応しているけど
実は後ろで作っているのは
おじいちゃん
だからもし僕が ここにいる若い人たちが
お金を稼いで注文しようとした時は
もしかしたらみんな後継者が
いなくなっているかもしれないんですね
だから こだわりたい時に もう
物が手に入らなくなってるかも知れない —
僕はそこに危機感を覚えています
ただ その裏にもっと問題があって
実は後継者が不足しているっていうのは
もっとその裏に問題があって
それは こだわる人が減ったと
いうことなんです
みんな どんどんインスタントに
物を手に入れたがっているし
そっちのが簡単な訳です
さっき言ったように
最初は面倒臭い訳ですから
でも僕はこだわりに粋とか美学ってものが
存在すると思うし
もっとみんな 格好良くなれる —
ポテンシャルがあると思っている
だから僕の今のテーマっていうのは
「どうやったら服
もしくは物事全てに
こだわれる人間が増えるかな？」
ということなんですね
で 僕なりに考えていて
どうやったら人に魅力を伝えられるのかな？
それはまあ こうやって
人に話すことが１つですよね
あとは日本にも同じ問題が存在していて
それは例えば着物とか
伝統文化とかですよね
で その友達に
「星野さん ぜひ一度来て下さい」と
新潟県十日町に呼ばれたんです
十日町は 何が有名か
みなさん知っていますか？
１つ目はコシヒカリですね
これはもうみんな美味しいから
当然食べるんです
もう１つは日本酒 —
お米から作られる日本酒
そしてもう１つは
衣食住の中の「衣」ですけど
「苧（からむし）」っていう
変わった字なんですけど
麻の一種です
これは昔 当然着物として
着られていたんです
だけどここにみなさん
ここに着物を着てる人は一人もいないです
いたら教えて欲しいんですけど —
着物を着ている人はいない訳で
だから 当然 スーツよりも
危機的な状況になってるんですけどね
だれも注文しない
僕は日本の魅力をイタリアに
伝えられたらもっと面白いと思うし
イタリアの魅力をみなさんに伝えるために
僕はここに立っている
だから今何をしようかな？
と思ってて悩んでいる最中です
で まあ 趣味の延長もあって
ふんどしを作ってみたんですよ
それが 今日のこれですね
（笑）
これ — カメラさん これを
多めにして欲しいんですけど
（笑）
やめて下さい
で 次なんですけど —
スライドお願いします
次は 実は [苧の]
スーツも友人が作ってみてるんです
要するに昔から使われてる —
これは 縄文時代から
歴史的にはあるんですけど
麻、リネンというものを使って
当然着物は当たり前ですけども
こういう下着にもできるし
実は今風のスーツにもできる訳です
で これ大変申し訳ないんですけど
ミャンマーの工場に依頼して
届くはずだったんですけど
ちょっとトラブルがあって
今日みなさんに見せられず
大変悔しい限りなんですけど
彼に着せるつもりで
ここに呼んでいるんですけど
（笑）
結果的に今恥ずかしい —
まあ 恥ずかしくはないか
まあこういう思いをしている訳ですね
（笑）
いいですか？
ということで 呼んだ訳です
ということで 今日
僕がみなさんに伝えたかったのは
本当にただ こだわりを知って欲しい
ということだけなんです
僕は筋肉を研究して
今スーツを研究しようとしています
そんな僕だからこそ言えることは
筋肉を変えれば 自分が変わってくるし
スーツを着ることで もっと自分の
物への態度っていうのが変わると思うんです
僕は そういう 例えば
洗練された物や一流の物を目指す人が
「粋」「格好いいね」と思われるような社会が
みんなが尊重しあえれば
いいと思います
ということで もし良ければ みなさん
今後もスーツも楽しんで欲しいし
スーツに関して今日話しましたけど
全ての物に対して言えることなので
ぜひ 物にこだわりを持って欲しい
というのが
今日 みなさんに伝えたいことでした
それでは ありがとうございました
（拍手）